a regular summer day as a kid hmm you go
to a gas station out where did you get
your money first of all my mom had a
chart if you were good you started out
with a dollar at the beginning of the
week all right and you got checks on
there when you were bad so everybody got
check my little sister though she was
always sick so she got all her money
because she couldn't do anything bad she
was ill so then we would get her money
to me and my brother would take borrow
her money from her right and break each
other off $0.50 each so I'd roll out at
about 60 cents over to that 7-eleven
I'd get myself [ __ ] two packs of
garbage pail kid cards bro
I'm saying cuz I start around my boys
remember that loogie Larry snotty Scotty
ha ha ha
remember balm Tom and his having a flat
Pat steamroll yeah yeah yes some were a
little dark like way lewd [ __ ] Donald
damn and he just have a couple pills and
his kids are [ __ ] crying by the cops
to get coked up with a dude they used to
put a string on his wrist mm-hmm and the
string would go to the door the price
get high with some crazy people yeah I
used to get high with his brother who
was bald and his brother would be
talking to him like we'd be doing coke
yeah yeah and also he go he smack him so
cuz he kept thinking flies with his head
he would smack himself 80 [ __ ] times a
night and and we would laugh at every
[ __ ] time and bat Pete's magnum self
ego I had another friend Kurt he used to
get so paranoid that he would put little
parachutes
his cocaine so I can't aim he would
throw out the window it will perish
that's the [ __ ] that was the Aidan's God
ladies is good bro everything is so much
fun back dinner I feel like there was so
much more mystery and intrigue like when
I was growing up than there is now
because I was at a place in New Orleans
a while back and somebody got CPR and I
loved that kind of [ __ ] you have four
[ __ ] fresh crab appetizers rolling on
the table dude and so he might die
[ __ ] 11 feet away from you so this
lady was you know someone going well the
husband wasn't really interested in save
he's like what's going on he can't pass
her like six times and she you know I'm
not good at charades but I can obviously
tell what somebody keeps pointing at
their throat and not being able to
breathe em pointing it like shrimp he's
like what do you want you want me to
order something else so then this dude
this one guy was pretty jacked up on
some uppers brah
the kind of guy looked like he owned a
dolphin once he's gonna do the Heimlich
it takes his shirt off oh my god he
starts going in on this lady and the
shrimp eventually shoots out and bro 9
minutes later they're having dessert
it's crazy how quickly you forget that
you were just about to die but now I go
back here this a year later and he said
yeah we can't do CPR anymore so
somebody's dying you just have to like
be there for you just Klout Go Go oh
yeah because you would you don't know a
lot of people don't realize Noah's Ark
came from England or yeah and landed in
America and a lot of the animals got off
but some of the animals they've been you
know smoking weed and doing brothel and
you know doing sex down there selling
you know that body crotch and did they
stayed on the boat so Noah's Ark so it
hit the waters again ends up in
Australia that's when all these bootleg
a man will start rolling off the thing
they got like a hyena and I and I'm like
a marmoset had had a baby and that's how
the kangaroo happen and that [ __ ]
hopped right off and start to fight
[ __ ] fighting people right at the
dock then koalas bro they just hi there
they are the snoop dog of the animal
kingdom you feel me them [ __ ] always
just snacking on that green and
sometimes they'll have a video they get
so hot I just fall right out the tree I
mean that's I don't know if all that's
in the Bible but it should be you know I
like that movie uh Bridges of Madison
County well it just shows that you can
get love in different places and that
there's different levels to love in
different parts of love some love you
get from here and some love you get from
there so I liked that movie Bridges
Madison County and it's about bridges
man bridges you know cuz think about
this before bridge is what people had to
try and jump over something so if you
wanted to get a message to somebody
across the whatever water dragon area
you had to [ __ ] get a buddy feed him
a bunch of steaks and everything train
him you know tell him he was gonna make
it and then send him out there running
dragon god I'm saying so bridges or
everything cuz before that you had to
get wet or get eaten or get burnt name
you know name 11 other things that are
better than that
I stopped into the fighter and the kid
the other day you know and I had a nice
chat and they were Bryan Callen and he
is if you're not familiar with him he
was I don't think he was in the Old
Testament but he was in the New
Testament and he was a Jedi or something
no no way but he he's seen many many
moons
you know Native Americans know him
there's drawings of him on on cave walls
and these aren't rumors these are real
things if you put your ear up to a
seashell that you find on a mountain you
can hear it ask for Bryan Callen
apparently one time a huge wave came and
and at the same time a rainbow was
shooting through the sky and the wave
was like a hundred feet high and at the
same moment an eagle flew right in and
there was like a triumvirate of water
and rainbow in any gallon and that they
say is when Bryan Callen became you know
they had a boy in our area that is born
in wild Jacob at one time his uncle I
remember pass through town or something
gave him a little hammer but while Jacob
would just get off in the woods and he
find him a little tree or something or a
little you know area of hardness maybe a
fence board or a piece of stone and he
would just hit it with that hammer just
just for hours and hours in chair Noble
or somewhere or rush or you know who
knows outerspace they're thinking of it
some wild unique morse code is coming in
you'd come out of the school or out of
your house and he would have chiseled a
damn Deion Sanders into the side of the
Honda I go what the [ __ ] man but I'm
just saying while Jacob was out there
all day with a freaking wanted him a
little baby hammers son this room real
range in the world open and I mean I
swear to God we thought we had a damn
woodpecker in the neighborhood for
probably four years so it's nighttime
right right and it's raining what year
is that I have to know what year it is
it's whenever you guys died dude 60 70
1967 Alabama Alabama
we're [ __ ] hanging a did its Alabama
okay you're in the stocks I think you're
gonna do something more like hang me up
or something
I don't think hanging it's like a
surprise party I think what's your name
again my name is Reggie I'm gonna call
you master Reggie then I mean you can
that's - Reggie own it so say it's you
like okay can you sneak me out of here
I can probably come back tomorrow night
and help you tonight I can just give you
water and also have this small bag of
fresh pears oh I love pear thank you I
know you do um but if they're gonna hate
me tomorrow then what's tomorrow night
gonna what is that gonna do yeah it's
good point actually gonna be a little
late
yeah say something inspirational to me
very cool even though a lot of the books
and stuff just show that God just you
know has like a lot of white people in
heaven that everybody's allowed in
heaven will I be able to go in the white
sections of heaven you can stop by
you know I haven't been part of a street
fighting I don't know how long last one
that I could think of that I've been in
was one Mardi Gras down in Lafayette
Louisiana I was at my brother's house
and it was like a street party then my
wife was leaning over a fence talking to
somebody guys from next door came over
and like bent over her back and put his
hand on her stomach and like started
talking in her ear mm-hmm and then uh
bro you just saw red yeah I ripped him
off I had a buddy of mine who fights he
started dropping this other guy's people
left and right
100% every shot that landed everybody
fell he shot a hundred percent from the
field that night then I started punching
this guy and then he he had a lot more
friends than we did and my brother is
not a fighter so he didn't run it he
didn't run out of the house to come
fight but it was just like people were
fighting every and I ended up getting my
back up against a car cuz they were
jumping yeah I was like yeah and I got
hit with a bunch of uppercuts it was
crazy man Mardi Gras things a lot of
guys that's one thing I do miss about
Mardi Gras me everybody would drink all
day and anything could happen
you could start a family you could start
a fire sort of family you can start a
fight sometimes I take a little bit of
flack for saying this but you gotta like
get control of your emotions yeah you
gotta like say okay you know what this
girl left me or this job I lost or I had
this happen to me when I was a kid you
got to say you know what okay I'm not
gonna let that situation control me and
I'm gonna I'm gonna take control of my
emotions and I'm gonna move forward you
got to assert yourself you know your
mind is stronger than those little
emotions that are running around inside
your head you can overpower them yeah I
can do it if you don't do it they're
they're gonna run wild and they don't
deserve to they don't know what they're
doing they're just up there making noise
and going crazy and running around and
and calling things out it's like no you
stop
get control of those emotions you've got
to do it sometimes and a lot of people
say hey that's that's not it's not easy
for everyone I get that it's not easy
but man the alternative is like just let
your emotions run run everything and run
you into the dirt don't don't let that
happen man I get ya I grab hold of them
get control and like you said starts
taking a step in the right direction
that's where it starts man I love that
man
did you enjoy that clip well you really
would have enjoyed it if he was watching
on a TCL TV TCL is America's fastest
growing TV brand it's so fast it's the
Carl Lewis of television brands it's
that Florence Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its fifth anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com